but we can this half-hour with some new
security technology you might have seen
on your holiday travels airlines are
starting to test facial recognition
devices in some airports around the
country they are hoping the technology
could improve safety speed up the
boarding process and may even replace
the need to carry a passport but these
devices are also raising questions about
privacy CBS News Transportation
correspondent Kris Van Cleave explains
you can board without presenting your
boarding pass passport or other travel
documents this JetBlue flight leaving
Boston for Aruba has passengers taking a
trip to the future without a boarding
pass I'm just gonna walk up and they're
gonna take a picture and that's it Wow
yeah it amazes me every year things
changed it just amazes me the technology
in seconds facial recognition technology
can compare a picture taken at the gate
against a Flyers passport pictures
stored in a government database Francis
Sadowski is sold pretty fast Delta is
testing the technology in New York and
Atlanta and is also trying out a facial
recognition bag drop in Minneapolis part
of a larger effort that envisions your
face or fingerprint as the only thing
you'll need to navigate an airport
marrying all of the technologies at each
of the steps in the travel ribbon is a
game-changer for the experience you can
literally go from your curb to plane
without having to interact with a human
being if you so desire
there's also clear a private company
that for a fee will store and verify
fliers biometrics allowing people to go
to the front of the security line at 24
airports nationwide but a new report
questions if it's legal for the
government to use facial recognition on
American citizens and two senators are
asking Customs and Border Protection to
halt expansion of the testing amid
security concerns as we consolidate
biometric data into big databases and we
use it more and more those databases
will become targets in it and the risk
of data breach increases greatly the TSA
is testing fingerprint verification at
at least two airports in the US and here
at Reagan National certain Delta
customers can use their fingerprint as
their boarding pass Kris Van Cleave CBS
News Arlington Virginia the future is
now done I don't know if you believe
that Mission Impossible movies people
are gonna be making masks of me and
trying to go places they already are
dying